ralphie may used to live right behind me
oh really and um
well i got some good ralph and may
stories but my favorite he was
we were going he was like josh well
we're going to jack in the box to get
some jack in the box for everybody
and i said all right so we get into his
he was driving a 4runner at the time
how long was this oh man
99 we were all just kind of starting and
ralphie was the only one who had a
little bit of dough
might have been 2 000. you're so good
and uh we lived right next to our
right we both lived behind el compadre
man that place was you know joey diaz
was around there jay moore was always
around
ron white was around for a little while
monsters uh and how good was jay moore
dude but ricky cruz was around at the
time oh really yep
um jesus christ so uh
that's when i used to go that was around
that time when i was going and we would
mean when chelsea handler and i were
going out and doing ecstasy all the time
and
it was a good time dude jesus sounds
like the best of times oh it was a good
time
so but ralphie was like come on josh
what are we gonna go get some
jack-in-the-box for everybody
so we go get some jack-in-the-box and he
orders this huge order
and he goes put that in one bag and he
goes here's for another bag
and he orders another order and um
i go what's that second bag for he goes
it's for the ride home and i said what
he goes this is
i have my at home food and i get my ride
home
and i go oh okay and so the two bags
come and we put the enormous bag in the
back
by the way the ride home bag was not
small pretty [ __ ] big and he goes
open that glove compartment
all the condiments hot sauce relish i
love it
mustard salsa he was like hammy same
with that tapatio
he had the condiments in the glove box
dude
ralphie may was a generous generous
generous to a fault dude yeah he's
always nice to me i remember me and him
i was coming back or i fee or maybe i
was going i think i was going to like
west niagara new york i forget where i
was going somewhere far
and uh it stopped in phoenix and he was
going to phoenix i think to do
shows or something we were both on
southwest it was a layover for me
and we both sit down and i'm in the the
right side and he's on the left he was
man
we too and i didn't even realize it was
him he was man we too [ __ ] big to be
on southwest man
and i looked over and you know he's 400
pounds like we
at least my size goes up and down yeah
yeah
it kind of fit i mean yeah
we yeah excuse me sir man okay so here's
another good ralph it made story it was
in nashville
now sarah tiano and i were on the road
together she's great by the way
and by the way as far as roast jokes
she's gonna [ __ ] kill you she's a
beast she's gonna kill you she had a
baby huh yes
and ralphie may's down at the show and
he's talking to sarah tiana on stage
and saying things like seratiana i don't
know sarah tiana
and justin people are laughing they know
they know ralphie and they
and you know that at zany's in nashville
there's not too much separation from the
stage this far
barely any right so she said i'm gonna
butcher her joke but basically she said
rafi mae is here everybody ralphie
actually just started
taking yoga so he's soon so soon he'll
be flexible enough to
kiss both of his feet goodbye she was
like because diabetes is coming
and i was like that was a great diabetes
jokes
or was the fans dying oh they were dying
so we went out that night right
and ralphie was um
things were not going well with his with
his ex and um
and uh and she had already i think filed
for divorce and so we're out and
there was a yeah he was with this young
girl and and we're sitting there and
we're at this place at a bar in
nashville i don't remember the name of
it
but i heard this huge rumble
and i was like what the [ __ ] and i
turned around and ralphy had fallen off
the stool
oh man and i was like oh man he goes
josh will help me up i'm like help you
up like
let me get help yeah and he goes man you
go to the gym i go yeah but
i go to the gym i get on the tread bull
i don't lift it yeah
i can't lift you up bro and just then i
saw
there was the girl he was with who was
sitting on his lap i saw two little feet
sticking out from under ralphie
it was like that scene in wizard of oz
where the where the
where the because you just saw her socks
and i said oh
and i and he goes oh [ __ ] is she under
me right
hey there was like some guys i go we got
to get her under and so grabbing ralphie
was
a a he was 400 pounds in a dicey
situation it wasn't
for solid like it was you know what i
mean like if you grabbed him it was like
okay it was like kind of
goopy yeah and so we were like let's
rock him and we'll rock him and pull her
out
such a shame so we kind of rocked him
and lifted him up and pulled her out
and when we pulled her out dude this was
exactly what the noise she made we
pulled her out
and went yo when her head came out she
went like she had been underwater a
little thing
so tiny so i said she man when she came
out her eyes she was scared
she was like 400 people like this so i
we get her calm she's drinking a drink
she's up on a stool
we get ralphie up and i had to ask her i
go just let me ask you a question she
goes yeah
and i go what was it like under there
yeah and she goes
it was dark soft and warm
rafi died from uh was the overdose do we
know
he was a sick dude man yeah if you i
remember i remember
the first i heard of the he fell asleep
on stage at the lab factory i wasn't i
was like
for me yeah yeah
but if you look at the pictures from
before his death
like from a week before he literally
fell asleep like he was telling her
he was like doing this like crowd work
and then just fell asleep on the stool
look is she uh google ralphie picture
ralphie met ralphie may uh
i don't know how would you like right
there right before
died of high blood pressure
those were some of the pictures i think
those are actually some of the pictures
from
right before he passed no that wasn't it
but he doesn't look good there there it
is he was so
[ __ ] funny man he was so funny and
you know what i loved about him dude
he would do three hours
and his the the clubs would hate it but
i asked him i go why would you do that
much time and he said man the people
come to my shows don't have a lot of
money
so he was like i'm an hour's dude he
would do a lot of time dude the people's
at the club for me i just can't
yeah i've been to some clubs and they
were like uh like how long are you doing
you tell them like oh wow
like that's pretty standard yeah more
standard power standard like well carlos
macedo was here last week and he did
three and a half hours that's torque and
i was like how's that going like
people are walking out yeah like after
an hour two hours they're out man
it's it's a bit your bit jerking
yourself off at that point in time
bit of an ego thing i would rather have
people
there are sometimes late show saturday
where i'll tell people going in
i am going to be i'm taking 100
milligram edible
i'm going to be really high you can
leave it any time you want
cause i'm going to go because you're
going to go i want you to know i'm not
going to heckle you for leaving and this
is how i tell my crowds all the time
you won't hurt my feelings i've been
doing this a long time if this isn't
your deal
and you don't like it yeah thank you for
coming you're not going to hurt my
feelings
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler we got a [ __ ]
together
[Laughter]
dude grab that mic son